زينه تصر الناظرين لكنه عيد على وقع
اضرابات وازمات اقتصاديه واجتماعيه تودع
اوروبا العام بعلاقات مشحونه والصدميه
احيانا بين الحكومه والنقابات العماليه
حفله الاضرابات في بريطانيا بدات وستمر
حتى العام الجديد
للقيام بمهام موظفي مراقبه الجوازات في
مطارات المملكه ثمانيه مطارات في اضراب
شارك فيه الف عامل استنادا لنقابه الخدمات
العامه والتجاريه في يوم يتوقعوا فيه وصول
الربع مليون مسافر الى سته من المطارات
المشموله بالاضراب وصفه مسؤول النقابي
موظفي شرطه الحدود بالفقراء قال ان 40,000
منهم يستخدمون الطعام وخمسه واربعين الفا
يطالبون بتحسين الظروف العمل كان الاسبوع
الماضي حافلا بالتوقف العمل في عده قطاع
احتجاجا على رفض الحكومه زياده الاجور
تعاني بريطانيا ازمه غلاء معيشه ادت الى
ارتفاع التضخم بنحو 11 بالمئه وكان
المشاكل هنا لا تاتي فراده فقد اعلنت
الجمعيه الملكيه للتمريض عن اضراب القطاع
مجددا يومي 18 وال 19 من يناير العام
المقبل وكانت توقف سائقي سيارات الاسعاف
عن العمل خلال الاسبوع الماضي مقدمه لنفس
الخطوه في قطاع الصحه بمختلف اقسامه في
جدول غضب العمال اضرابات لعمال السكك
الحديديه وبعض عمال حافلات لندن
وحزين ويشعر بخيبته امل هكذا وصف رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك مشاعره تجاه
ما يجري في البلد قال ان التحدي
الاقتصاديه الاكبر الذي يواجهه الجميع هو
التضخم تضخم يقدم ان رواتب الجميع
[موسيقى]
فرنسا ثاني اكبر اقتصاد داخل البيت
الاوروبي ليست افضل حالا الرحله خلال فتره
اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه لا سعيده ولا
ممتعه اضراب عمال السكك الحديديه قلب راسا
على عقب برنامج الرحلات وتحديدا عبر
القطارات فائقه السرعه تاثر من ذلك 100
الف مسافر بعد الغاء قطارين فائقين السرعه
من اصل خمسه تلبيه مطلب رفع الاجور قد لا
تكون ممكنه لان فرنسا ايضا تعاني من عدوى
التضخم والاسوء واتم يقول المسؤولون
والمحللون الاقتصاديون اسنادا لوزير
الماليه
مستويات تضخم مرتفعه في شهور قليله
المقبله لا سيما في اسعار المواد الغذائيه
قبل ان يتراجع على الارجح في منتصف عام
انت ماشي من اقتصادي
اجتماعيه ومساعدات مستمره للحليب في
اوكرانيا هكذا تودع اوروبا عمل قاسيا
وستدخل اخره بتريكته الثقيله